[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
will be my brand new Spider-Man 4 video
there's a bunch of great news that we
just heard they're getting ready to
start filming the movie Tom Holland's
been talking about a little bit too so
we'll break it all down if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos there's going to
be a lot of Spider-Man related stuff
happening in 2024 in 2025 so like we
have the Spider-Man freshman year TV
show that's coming at the end of 2024
they've actually renamed that friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man I think to avoid
some confusion about where it fits in
the Multiverse in the grand scheme of
things I already did a much bigger
trailer video about that so I'll link it
at the end of this there's like a big
2024 push into animation that Marvel is
doing during 2024 like X-Men 97 and it
is full morbin time in 2024 for Sony
like there's The Madam Web movie which
is kind of like Mor for women and then
there's also the Craven movie it's
Craven time coming later in the year one
of the funny things about Tom Holland's
Spider-Man 4 even though it's like their
big Marquee movie there's a bit of a
tug-of-war happening behind the scenes
between Marvel and Sony as to how
connected it's going to be to that Venom
spin-off Universe basically Sony wants
it to be full morbin time for Tom
Holland's Spider-Man like bring him into
our universe because there was that big
morbius post credit scene where they
referenced Spider-Man and they this big
Sinister 6 spin-off movie that they're
setting up they want to have a big
Sinister 6 franchise separately from the
Venom movies and all these other movies
that's where they're setting it up in
the morbius post credit scene has to do
with Spider-Man I think I'm still
figuring this place out but I think a
bunch of guys like us should team up
apparently they really want that
Spider-Man to be Tom Holland Spider-Man
even though there are a number of other
available spidermen that they could use
like Andrew Garfield Spider-Man they
could even use liveaction Miles Morales
if they're not going to be making that
movie for a couple more years that would
give Sony a bunch of time to release
Spider-Man beyond the spiderverse and
complete miles morales's Arc in the
spiderverse movies which Lord and Miller
basically said would happen like at the
end of beyond the spiderverse that will
be the end of Miles morales's storyline
at least in those movies I think that's
just because when Spider-Man across the
spiderverse came out a while ago Amy
Pascal revealed that they had plans to
do a liveaction Miles Morales movie so
they're planning to transition to him
inside their big Sony Universe of Marvel
characters or the Venom Universe however
you want to think about it but probably
some of the best news so far about
Spider-Man 4 is that Marvel wants to
keep it a very groundlevel friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man kind of a vibe
in the movie with a lot of Daredevil in
it and the Kingpin character there have
been so many rumors about them since the
events of Spider-Man no way home like
you have that quick Daredevil Cameo
scene and like the extended version you
have a little bit more Daredevil in it
they had some of the greatest energy
together and Daredevil is probably one
of the other preeminent ground level
characters inside the Marvel Universe
and they're basically trying to take
Spider-Man in a more ground level
Direction More friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man Direction way less of the
Iron Man way less Tech like more lowii
just in general much less of a big
Multiverse movie which I think a lot of
people will be excited about even though
Spider-Man no way home was amazing with
all the full Multiverse stuff that it
got into I think we're getting to the
point where the Multiverse Saga and
Marvel has gotten a little long in the
tooth people are ready to have Avengers
5 King Dynasty Avengers 6 Secret and to
move past the Multiverse Arc supposedly
the plan in Spider-Man 4 is to still
have it take place before Avengers 5 and
Avengers 6 but just to keep it a little
more self-contained like less Multiverse
stuff going on than there was during
Spider-Man no way home one of the only
problems with that though is that Sony
still has a lot of control even though
Marvel technically per their sharing
contract has most of the creative
control over what happens in that movie
but there's just like a big argument
going on behind the scenes and obviously
Marvel wants to continue using
Spider-Man after this Spider-Man 4 movie
in Avengers 5 so do not be surprised if
you continue to hear arguments about
Marvel and Sony going back and forth
about how connected Tom Holland is going
to be to this Sony Universe of Marvel
characters until Spider-Man 4 actually
comes out and we see those post-credit
scenes they're still trying to release
the movie by summer 2025 like July 2025
that's usually the target date for most
Spider-Man movies but if they don't
actually start filming the movie really
soon they're going to miss that date so
they'd have to release it either
Christmas 2025 which isn't that big of a
deal or push it to 2026 but in reality
they've delayed most of the Marvel
movies that were going to happen next
year to 2025 so if they're going to
delay Spider-Man for a year that's not a
huge deal either Tom Holland has issued
a couple official statements like his
official stance is that he'll just
continue playing Spider-Man forever
basically as long as there are good
scripts he's not going to film a movie
just to film a Spider-Man movie he said
that right after the strikes ended so
that's probably just code for we're not
quite done with the script yet so like
the movie doesn't look exactly like a
full movie yet the funny thing about
Spider-Man no way home too is that he
said that the script changed every
single day they were filming on that
movie and if you asked him what the big
third act final battle with the Statue
of Liberty was going to be when they
started filming the movie he would have
had no idea because they hadn't even
finished writing that scene yet in fact
I talked about this during my Spider-Man
no way home deleted scenes videos
because there were many deleted scenes
there were like many different versions
of the movie with many different types
of team ups if they did not have Toby
Maguire and Andrew Garfield Spider-Man
like they had a bunch of contingency
plans for instance we had that Venom
crossover scene in the post credit scene
originally he was actually meant to be
at that big Statue of Liberty battle he
would have been a much bigger character
which is why during the post credit
scene he talks about going to New York
City to talk to Spider-Man originally
that scene was going to come much
earlier in the movie and he would have
gone to New York City and fought in that
big final fight probably explaining how
Tom Holland Spider-Man winds up getting
the Symbiote too because he would have
left the piece of the Symbiote closer to
New York City where it would come into
contact with Tom Hall and Spider-Man as
far as I know though Spider-Man 4 will
not be the actual start of the Symbiote
Saga they're pushing that off just like
a little bit later in the story but they
might tease it a little bit during the
movie like the Symbiote piece might get
a little bit closer to him in some of
the post-credit scenes but it sounds
like Daredevil is a much bigger part of
the story even though Kingpin would not
be like the main villain right now the
antagonists that are in the movie or
villains however you want to think about
them are Kingpin and the vulture
character coming back the funny thing
about the vulture coming back is that he
was also in a bunch of deleted scenes
from Spider-Man no way home like if you
look at this scene here he's clearly
taking the Sinister Six characters to
the vultures house to try and deal with
them I don't know how far this got into
production before they decided to remove
the vulture I think they just got too
overstuffed with characters and they had
Toby McGuire and Andrew Garfield
Spider-Man like okay we have them we
don't need to have like a billion other
characters but just like Kingpin
obviously vulture would not be the main
villain again like he just be one of the
antagonists in the movie that would also
probably help Spider-Man at some point
during the film they haven't said who
the actual main villain is going to be
it would probably be a brand new
Spider-Man villain from the comics that
they have not done in the MCU yet but
you can kind of see with all these
deleted scenes from the previous
Spider-Man movies even like the morbius
movie with all the Spider-Man stuff in
it that they removed before they
actually released the movie all the
Venom stuff that early on they were
actually planning to have a Spider-Man
versus Venom movie much much earlier but
I think the idea is they just came up
with a much stronger idea for what they
wanted the Spider-Man movies to be so
like no we don't need all this big
crossover stuff with Venom morbius all
the Sony stuff it sounds like the movie
is still supposed to come out after the
events of Daredevil born again so
Kingpin will become mayor of New York
City during Daredevil born again even
though they've changed the plot of that
I'll explain that in a second there have
been a bunch of changes behind the
scenes with Daredevil born again but
part of the idea is that Vincent and
offo teased that he would go up against
Spider-Man eventually a while ago and it
sounds like they're actually going to
finally pay pay that off in some way
even though like I said he probably
won't be the main villain of the movie
there's only one really end goal you
know and I think somebody just said who
that would
be Peter Parker not Spider-Man Peter
Parker have no idea what you're in store
for with porn
again and and I know all that Kingpin
stuff Kingpin becoming mayor of New York
City is part of that big Marvel Phase 5
dark rain that they have going on in the
background with villains slowly coming
to power it's like a loose adaptation of
dark rain in the comics with some
different characters previously I would
have said this all spins out of what
happened at the end of secret Invasion
with the US president Ritson basically
going full nuclear on the Scrolls like
we are going to clamp down hard it will
be like a military State around the
world till we get rid of all these
Scrolls but because they flubbed secret
Invasion so hard like there were so many
complaints about the secret Invasion
series I think they're just trying to
avoid reference seeing secret Invasion
as much as possible so even though the
ending of that series with the US
president precipitates a lot of the dark
rain stuff that's happening across all
the movies and all the TV shows I think
they'll just avoid mentioning the events
of secret Invasion as much as possible
I've already done videos about Zena
coming back in Spider-Man 4 I don't know
about Ned leed's coming back there's all
these jokes about him becoming a version
of hobgoblin in the previous Spider-Man
movies so people are like are they going
to do that in Spider-Man 4 finally there
are even deleted scenes from Spider-Man
no way home with him on Green Goblins
glider going full hobgoblin like they're
clearly referencing him becoming
hobgoblin because he's throwing one of
the pumpkin bombs during this but I
don't think that they're going there in
Spider-Man 4 like I think this was just
an idea for Spider-Man no way home that
they decided not to do at the last
minute so they're just kind of leaving
it off like we could always do this in
the future if we want but probably not
over on the Daredevil Born Again side of
things you probably I did a couple
videos they basically cancelled the
original version of Daredevil born again
because Kevin fogy apparently saw all
the dailies and just hated what they
were doing it basically turned the show
into more of a legal procedural like Law
and Order type of show with not a lot of
Daredevil in it and not a lot of action
either and you just felt like people
would just be super pissed off if you
saw a daredevil show without Daredevil
doing a lot of Daredevil stuff so they
basically fired the previous creative
team on that show hired a bunch of the
Punisher Netflix people and a bunch of
the Loki people after Loki season 2 to
redo that show with some of the existing
footage but there's a bunch of big stuff
coming up in 2024 we still have that
animated Spider-Man show of course I'll
do episode videos for that we probably
won't get a trailer for that for a while
but I have done a couple teaser trailer
videos and trailer videos for the stuff
that they have released already click
here for that Spider-Man freshman year
trailer video to learn what's going on
with that series and click here for my
X-Men 997 teaser trailer video to learn
what's going on with that thank you so
much for watching everyone stay safe and
I'll see you guys in the next
one
he